[音楽]
me
th
お前ら
[音楽]
俺にドッキリを仕掛け始めさん
僕にそんなことできませんん
うーん
ああああああああ
お前てるじゃなーい
いいか
横列をドッキリを仕掛ける側だ
誰もリード切り落ちかけてくれない
そうだの確かに
言われてみればあ
exile なぁ
ということだ俺は今から睡眠に入る
お前たち
俺に特大のドッキリを仕掛けてくれ
何でもしてい何でも好きなことしていいぞ
燃やすや燃やすって誰だ痛いのもよし苦しいでもよし
お前たちが望む
最高にやりたいドッケ料
俺ね仕掛けてくれ
分かりません
源さんのためなら
罪を犯しても
ドッキリを仕掛けます
布団で待ってねー
4日
い
[音楽]
ん
しねえゆなそして俺たちは者
後半ユーチューバーとして
一市長に寝起きドッキリを仕掛けることになったん
この俺があのバカなもの特急に引っかかると100人払えばお
フレで作れ俺
[音楽]
ん
うんん
me
ああああああああおはようございます
[音楽]
早ならええええええ
おはようございますございます
おはようございますあります
ええええええ
me
dea
うううううあっ
秋の時ないようですね
寝起きにいろんな感じを出させるっていうどっちなんですけど
まず1つ目わーんうるさいうるさいうるさーがですね
暑いとさんが入っ
ぺ at 掲げたんですねネットトレース秒キャットかけません
次にいたい
配膳年たち今できません
次に楽しいシャボンのあればっ楽しいないっ
次に汚いターン